[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to folks
we need to talk about the BART man let's
go back to a simpler time when a cartoon
voice wearing was the most shocking
thing on TV though any idea where this
bastard lives Bart it's no question that
the Simpsons has shaped and redefined
humor for so many of us but oh forget in
the early years they were not only
popular they were insanely popular well
Bart was insanely popular with
commercials toys video games and
countless t-shirts Bart mania as
everyone called it and by everyone I
mean Fox executives what's on fire
people especially kids ate up his
anti-authority nature especially when
authority itself tried stomping him out
make American families a lot more like
the Waltons and a lot less like The
Simpsons
thank God that did backfire how many
times were you president George at the
height of his popularity Bart was given
what every popular icon in the early 90s
was given a music video do the BART man
was one of the many songs on the hit
album Simpsons sing the blues and in
1991 it was given its own special video
airing on Fox it was filled with every
late eighties cliche trying to turn into
early 90s cliches but what makes this
stand out it's not just the video itself
but the fascinating story in the making
of the video now granted I've never
reviewed a nostalgic song before but I
present that argument with this picture
of Bart waving his ass at you I
understand the story behind the video
though we must first analyze the video
itself so journey back to a time when
this was risky this is do the BART man
The Simpsons are off to see Bart's
fourth-grade recital which unfortunately
has him all the way in the back but Bart
will fight back those boring adults
whose 90s commercials explain just don't
get us bubble tape is not part of a
well-balanced diet as he plugged in his
own music
oh dear I feel an impromptu ninja rap
coming on he starts rapping in front of
the crowd about what a troublemaker he
is that Skinner has to look up his file
to see who he's dealing with time
believing Skinner doesn't know who this
kid is by now he's going to introduce
the next face I'm so excited to see
what's up next for the BCU keep them
proceeds to tell us how to do the BART
man I assume it ties in with awkwardly
time baseball catching those boys
testicles dropped
got to get credit to a song that
recommends do the BART man if you can as
in are able to not everybody is Bartman
accessible I also got a love a kids
music video that shows school figures
taking a shot out of a flask my mom said
it was chocolate milk and I still stand
by that and judging by that reaction it
was probably you who of course the fart
man can't be contained and has to make
its way to the streets where the BART
man was practically born it was dice
lines of coke at the BART man we segue
to a couple of weeks ago when he was
sent to his room for putting mothballs
in the Beast do could perhaps doing the
BART man change his woes I call false
advertising I purchased the first comic
there was no mention of this dance move
at all no thanks I've seen what your
interpretation of Michael Jackson looks
like I'm not impressed
Bart sneaks out of his suburban home
which has suddenly been moved to a more
urban landscape perhaps it was shot when
they moved to capital city as he
continues to explain how to do the BART
man without actually showing us how to
do the BART man
yeah weirdly enough Bart never does the
BART man in this music video isn't that
like singing the hokey-pokey but doing
the electric slide but Homer interrupts
their fun telling them to turn it down
[Music]
you can't stop less you'll fart
Department as a movement part places
ears after hearing the most sound
grading of instruments wait until they
ain't that Nickelback kid Bart is so
popular even dogs are converting their
language to his name terrifying I know
but it's still less creepy than the Bart
Simpson phone
Bart's Posse awaits is ever dope rhymes
there's an irony that years later Bart
would have a posse from rapping being
what the show calls a prankster a rapper
but they don't have the air swimming
vibes these badasses have Bart isn't
really rapping about much he says how to
do the Bart man let his backup singers
demonstrate never doing it himself
then perhaps about getting sent to his
room and hearing Lisa's saxophone
doesn't seem like much cause for a high
production music video but then again
neither to Kazaam and i forget what my
point was we cut the people all over the
world not doing the bar man even
barflies asses get caught up in the beat
and what the hell there's an action
figure of alien mr. burns but not these
background characters actually I forget
which ones which look even skinnier and
Krabappel have decided to join in they
were so angry before but now they're
just dancing along that's the power of
the BART man if unites all people
through its rock-like motion or bitter
drinking it's probably bitter drinking
do all go the cause oh and solution to
all of life's problems even mr. burns
his security is getting into it and
heads up this is the funniest scene in
the video
see I told you Carl was gay no no not
that car anyone named Carl on the show
is gay even the church and Satan can see
eye to eye over the BART man powerfully
they can stop possessing everyone's
upper half of the face you pause those
scenes too don't act like you didn't but
the song comes to an end as it looks
like yo it's all part of Bart's fantasy
oh good I can still consider this part
of the Simpsons kin and I'd hate for
their continuity to get us queued do the
Bartman I guess not surprisingly was a
big hit it reached number 11 on the
Billboard charts top several other
charts all over the world was played on
MTV for several months and made their
Simpsons sing the blues album go
platinum it even went to a sequel music
video called deep deep trouble also
featuring bart rapping about him being
punished it seemed like all the hard
work paid off and what do you expect
when now world famous director Brad Bird
was in charge that's right the director
of Iron Giant and The Incredibles movies
got his start directing Simpsons
episodes and according to Burt himself
he said this was the hardest thing he'd
ever done the video was apparently so
rushed that they had to storyboard it in
just two days then fly out to Vargo
studio in Hungary and do the show in
only two and a half weeks
holy God it takes me a month to animate
a ball bouncing on my post-it notes this
was only two and a half weeks explains a
little bit why some of the background
characters don't quite look finished but
honestly I kind of prefer this style of
animation over the recent style of
animation get me wrong the recent style
is very clean smooth and allows for more
jokes to be squeezed in but the old
style had so much more life to it they
felt like they were leaping off the
screen and this video is one of the best
examples of it funny enough there was
apparently even a choreographer which I
guess makes sense we can compare the
dancing in the show to the dancing here
look at that gif animation go bottom
line they worked their asses off for
this and it clearly shows not bad for a
Michael Jackson song oh yeah
that's another interesting side note
Michael Jackson apparently wrote this
song though not credited MEC Rayman
claims that Jackson called him up one
day said he was a big fan of the show
and wanted to give Bart a number one
single so we wrote produced and even did
the backup vocals for the song yep
that's apparently Jackson himself
singing those parts
[Music]
crating said he was shocked nobody
figured it out as bart references
Jackson twice in the song and as
graining put it who else would do that
well maybe not him
Brian Lauren the person who got credit
for writing and producing the song said
that despite granny's confession she was
the sole writer Grammy says Jackson
couldn't come out about it because he
was under contract with another studio
but Lauren states he was the only one
who wrote it
despite this rather large disagreement
Lauren did state that Jackson did
provide the title for the song the
backup vocals and yes requested that he
be mentioned in it that's ignorant or
ignorant I have no idea which one of
these is true but either way Jackson had
involvement with this song even leading
to a guest our appearance on the show
again being uncredited don't worry
though I'm sure Bart represented him
when he showed up to the American Music
Awards by Christ is that terrifying yeah
this is what doing the Bartman
apparently gets ya no jokes that's
pregnant Nancy Cartwright in there with
clear evidence now to why she did rap
city street kids if I had to act in that
I don't know what the hell I would say
yes to afterwards overall much like the
video the details are fuzzy but the
final product is really creative and fun
sure it's corny and rough around the
edges but that's kind of part of its
charm it has a wonderful amount of
energy that's trying every second
entertain you in a Musical or visual way
it's a product of the times and the
silly it's in most enjoyable ways I
don't know if a ton of people are gonna
be rocking out to the same time soon
but for me and the people who saw my
premiered we remember went for a short
enjoyably ridiculous amount of time
every kid was doing the apartment
bonus tiles are could a guy remember it
so you don't have to everybody if you
can do the Batman check your buddy turn
it out if you can't KITT do the button
yeah that is so 1991
[Music]
[Applause]
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out in this week we are doing
compassion international this is the
world's leading authority in holistic
child development through sponsorship
holistic child development means they
begin with prenatal care and go all the
way through leadership development for
qualified young adults it means they
take a long-term approach to what they
do and go beyond simple involvement in
the lives of the children and families
they serve all of their child
development programs provide
opportunities that encourage healthy
development in four areas spiritual
physical social and economic when it
specifically comes to child sponsorship
their child sponsorship program is the
only one validated as effective through
independent empirical research if you
look at their site in their YouTube
channel you can see all the various
people they helped in all the various
parts of the world including Africa Asia
Central America and South America click
on the link and see how you can help
them provide children with the
opportunity to rise above their
circumstances and become the best they
know they can be
[Music]
you